Jeffery's just really really really
handsome and had a beautiful smile
you're shy he's tall very athletic body
and he was very easy to dress can we
slip a jacket on you you know he looks
really big the John Alaska it's perfect
yeah well it came in with good personal
style it came in with a you know t-shirt
striped t-shirt and it fit well and
again he was aware that clothes need to
fit you especially if you're someone
who's that message shoe strings to his
jacket or shirt as I recall didn't he
have blue stripes and blue shoe strings
yeah again just a little jump the reason
you keep that nail longer so there's no
coke habit
in terms of his hair I think we took
down he had a bit short and then it kind
of popped out a little bit he had a
little bit of a ledge so you have to
really be careful and that was something
we did with few cuts
he looks pretty gorgeous if I were he I
wore that coloring and I would probably
color my style before would be very
clean very nice simple but not like
extreme fashion with normal people
yeah we wanted to put him in something
something casual something soft and you
know trying to keep his own personal
style and you loved what he was wearing
I think but but you know make him a bit
more grown-up you know a lot of guys
think they can't wear lighter colors in
the winter but I think what I love about
that and the thing that really toughened
up toughen it up is a military code look
into my camera lens remember you're
seducing the person on the other side of
the lens beautiful I'm just going to
shoot a few you are so handsome one
thing I left from Tom today was whatever
I do having a head don't kind of change
it just really go for it